lucasfilm lucasfilm
boy look what he started man
uh yeah george is kind of talented you
know we're just kind of talented man
cheers i i i just blown away you know
the indus industrial light and magic was
the was the uh the genius behind the
mask you know and it was wonderful to
watch those guys work it was incredible
yeah i mean i don't think george gets
enough credit everyone talks about star
wars but i don't think people understand
how much he changed the entire industry
with visual effects oh yeah everything
visual sound everything everything he
affected the whole game
he's just one of the great great he
should have his uh his face should be on
mount rushmore
of film
i he changed my life i mean literally
you know
um yeah so listen and you can't get
better that's the thing is like you can
do other great star wars stuff because
it's just an amazing you know an amazing
well of material and ideas but that
first series of films was a mythology
like joseph campbell said it was a
perfect mythology you know and i love
him i love him for it he's fantastic
i'll act i'm going to ask you do you
prefer star wars or do you prefer empire
strikes back
you know i oh yeah
i love star wars
but i got to tell you empire strikes
back has a special place for me
because there was a time i think i was
about
14 or 15
when that came out that i got the
soundtrack the john williams and i would
put it on my headphones while i was
while i was reading late at night i was
reading stephen king novels
and i would mix mediums i would i would
read salem's lot with the
with the soundtrack to empire strikes
back
and uh so it has all these wild
memory connotations for me that is
wonderful just wonderful
sir i could keep talking about this but
i want to obviously talk about why i get
to talk to you today um i i love your
performance in these sonic movies i'm
sure you hear that from everyone but i'm
so curious how much are you
doing
are you figuring things out like the
night before and the weeks leading up to
showing up on set and how much are you
sort of discovering in the moment some
of the mannerisms and the things that
you would like to accomplish
it's a combination of everything i mean
you cannot make a solid plan
you know and then come into the set and
enforce it you know because there are a
billion artists involved and they're
doing wonderful things you know you get
to the mushroom planet and you look
around and you realize that these these
uh artists have created an atmosphere
that will affect your performance and it
will affect your choices
those things that somebody created in a
in you know with
polyurethane suddenly becomes something
alive and and and part of the scene a
character in the scene and i feel about
inanimate objects and
the style and the artistic direction of
a set as a character their characters in
your piece you know so you have to deal
with those characters and so things
change and you have to stay on your feet
and uh
in the meantime i've written a hundred
jokes and
five of them will get in the movie i've
i've written i've come in with a hundred
ideas
i i'm always working when i'm doing a
film i'm generally exhausted to the
point of never wanting to do another
film when i'm finished and uh and but
you know picture this i okay i've been
told i i read in the script that i've
now got this
emerald energy this green emerald energy
and uh how does that affect me well it
makes me like basically
fifth sixth and seventh dimensional
where i can bend
time and space and i can do whatever i
want with this power
how would it affect me and one of the
ways i chose for it to affect me is that
i would be as a as a demigod would um
you know bored with playing and toying
with human beings i would start playing
games with myself and
one of the things that occurred to me is
i called
jeff the director and i said i said
could i speak as if through a
synthesizer you know
could i actually play the notes on an
imaginary keyboard and you could bring
them to life later on you know so my
game is next level
and whatever it is you know and uh
this is just me walking around in my
underwear in my apartment you know and
and uh and i'll come up with
i'll come up with
30 to 50 ideas in a day and you know a
few of them will go in and every once in
a while one of them will be something
the audience has never seen before and
that's what i count on i carpet bomb
[Laughter]
listen i already got to stop i'm just
going to say thank you so much for all
of your work i'm a really big fan i
really want to say thank you i
appreciate that very much thank you